hello and welcome to this video who I'm
playing Bugs Bunny with some characters
before and after the name okay so we got
a trump at Trump but the Trump okay you
should to see one hmm I have no idea
yeah probably you still go you six huh
real probably
hmm it's very odd
so queen a5 can you do something
directly yeah you know it looks odd and
you want to when I've got a it's the
only way I just have the night only for
okay when taking us probably something
you can do anyway I shouldn't go d6 that
much is clear
Queen a5 said mmm-hmm oh it just gives
me the bishop oh my god yeah
thank you I didn't even consider the
move just that's that's very comfortable
you have a Benoni without Queen's which
is nice and oops I wanted to go g6 of
course Jesus okay let's try to make it
look like I intended that I didn't want
you go h6 of course ah
it's it's extremely annoying to us after
g6 and I'm just like better for every
year because the Benoni without the dark
squared bishop for widest is just a joke
basically I can't try to take play
Knight h5 that's not a good idea I mean
you can what I didn't just blunder the
pond
soh was the problem take him
Oh didn't see that
ouch okay it doesn't work well I didn't
see it
okay so what's going on yet it's a bit
crazy everything go here
Knight b5 just going to seven yeah that
is a good square do a little bit boxed
in there you stare threat not really
unite c7 ain't no doesn't really doesn't
feel like a threat so I can regroup this
v6 and then Bishop to b7 I should try
maybe six evaporate be six next Nazi
seven will be 896 a bit a bit
off-putting
not slightly slightly odd I probably
have to do this move yeah it looks
really strange but I have to prevent
night to see seven then b6b should be
seven no yeah that's how to do it
no there should be several once the rock
is in game it's a win easily
he has two pawns but there
oops trades Wow but they're not really
helpful just over to aim the bishop at
the pawns yeah so that was a really odd
game yeah he should definitely play 92
and it's funny out the engine likes
white and I'm not too surprised because
I mean it's it looks really odd but when
I was thinking about it what am i doing
now I mean taking doesn't help me all
that much and if I play move like these
six you would probably go exactly f3 and
it's it's all backwards yeah if I go
back fo I mean 92 94 and then all this
didn't make any sense it's funny huh I
was actually considering this move yeah
attacking here but there's Crete to see
tune really on yeah probably the way I
did it doesn't really help I mean I
cannot even play these six this is the
funniest thing it's really weird okay
you played 92 Anna that just hands me a
nice nice advantage I'm surprised that
the engine is on zero it's kind of kind
of wrong black ass is obviously better
here and there's a multitude of reasons
there is first of all I have a pair of
bishops which is important but also the
whole benoni structure loses lots of
appear for wide without Queens because
you cannot really hope to gauge an
attack on the black King here I'm just
enjoying a nice position and of course I
should play g6 AGI
actually a move considered by the engine
I mean yeah if you can't prevent
therefore that move makes sense but aged
65 a little bit less so of course just
g6 is good g6 Bishop g7 and I'm better
okay
h6 mostly pink and TIG v is probably
what you should do once you have played
h6
you played g3 Bishop g7 I know no Knight
f6 and the engine is giving light to f8
that that makes a lot of sense actually
trying to develop this and put this on
to g6 to make more pressure against the
pawn that makes a lot of sense and I'd
have 6 intended this and okay I had this
little trap in mind but I didn't really
hope that he would fall for it it just
wins the house h4 and yeah I win
material didn't see this one coming but
it doesn't doesn't really save him but
she sinks in fact Wow Wow
that makes a substantial difference
uh-huh yeah I mean I can't like I'm not
really really organized so possible this
is this yeah now the natural move King
to e7 is probably not that fantastic
because of the page 7 remarkable what do
I do that night f2 and what was my
mistake I should play B for first ok
this isn't all that clear there's no
edge Kim hmm remarkable I don't think
yeah yeah yeah it's it's okay right
yeah I'm save young B 7 B 6
yeah and and it's a wind okay so what
exactly was what's the problem so I take
here takes here
it just isn't all that clear I mean the
engine actually a solid it gave Knight
g4 as an alternative threatening f6 and
it seems that white doesn't have of
course yeah it just hangs and there's f6
and the threat so this is in fact
clearly stronger no no I was I mean I
was overlooking Bishop b5 check so I
didn't really think about anything like
that okay guys thanks for watching